animals are currently used in laboratory
experiments to ensure the safety of
substances and to carry out biomedical
research to improve human health
however sometimes animal models poorly
resemble human diseases or physiology
it's hard for drug developers and
biomedical scientists to imagine that
high-tech solutions such as micro
devices and computer models could one
day replace a living being and change
this approach to scientific research
could we show them that organ-on-chip
technology which are devices designed to
reproduce specific features of organs in
the lab provide human relevance
information
we launched an organon chip laboratory
in the jrc's european reference
laboratory for alternatives to animal
testing also known as url egfam to start
investigating the use of these
technologies for chemical safety
purposes and to help our scientists
acquire hands-on experience
[Music]
we started by creating a
state-of-the-art laboratory with all the
instrumentation and expertise needed to
replicate relevant case studies the
first device we used can integrate
multiple organs on the same chip and
connect them with a physiological fluid
flow thus it allows for the study of
organ organ interactions and complex
biological problems
we recently initiated an experimental
campaign with such a device combining
liver and brain models to study the
neurotoxicity of pesticides this
approach will enable us to reproduce the
liver's metabolic function and evaluate
the effects of the parent and
metabolized compounds on the brain
performing long-term repeated dose
toxicity studies
[Music]
by demonstrating the validity of this
technology in real life we are helping
to create a credible option for
scientists who are conscious that animal
testing is not the way forward
this will also stimulate companies to
use organome chip technology and will
support its use in regulatory decision
making
last but not least this will ensure
higher levels of protection for human
health and the environment while
avoiding animal testing